avec les équipes on a préparé un
parcours de cactus c'est très simple
regardez ils sont là bas est ce qu'on
peut avoir un plot sur les équipes là
bas regardez sont tous avec des ballons
c'est très simple ils vont devoir faire
un parcours avec des ballons ils vont
devoir faire va mettre trente secondes
pour faire le parcours sont sans péter
un ballon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et la femme et au vtt enduro hotu rau
mais vite à 30 secondes quand il reste
autant est intéressante en commun
nas s'appuyer pour kelly merci echems
ont été dans les bulles deux là pour
donner de réponse il faut fermer le
label
alors on nous étions sur gad elmaleh qui
a fait une révélation et gad elmaleh
j'ai refusé dans ces questions peuvent
animer une émission aux états unis où je
vais remplir le stade de france avec les
ex de castries
allez y vite wave race pour un truc
d'oisien à lévis vas-y mamie pousse même
souffle pouce aux balais ou alors il
faut qu'elle soit plus grosse attention
qui me regardent encore belge de la part
de bad run est là ça va c'est pas ton
émission est vite vite vite vite il faut
pas que tu prête un ballon attention
attention
oui ouais
oui oui à les badges d'accès basées
bathie seras tu là dessus basi maxime
robin et maxime chéreau terminée
la barre l'avocat de laetitia l'idée sur
ses news lowrie david ont tout manigancé
la bataille judiciaire va durer dix ans
ou mamie rock étaient en maternelle avec
isabelle morini bosc
alors qu'a déclaré alors qu'il veut
faire la bulle qui veut faire la bulle
qui veut faire la bulle maximale
si tu fais ah oui quand-même 1.5 est pas
bien non c'est pas parfait
benjamin non non alibaba s'adorent voilà
c'est ça la foutrait ex femme me dit si
les salles oui alors l'oreille david en
ont tout bon exemple
bravo bonhomme mamani matthieu delormeau
a tenté par baby
beat et fais attention tu vas te blesser
quelque chose
pas mal pas mal ait ans avec le cactus
un canton est sain déjà atos
il a perdu un ballon mais ne l'a pas il
n'a pas prêté attention il n'a pas
commis de ballons vas-y vas-y ça te
rappelle que j'ai fait l'armée arrêts
non mais c'est terminé pour mathieu
delormeau c'est terminé oui oui c'est
terminé je vais demander à gaston
lagaffe et paddy gastaud m'a dit
attention c'est gaston lagaffe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien c'est gaston superbus est
perdu
tu vas jouer d'accord tu vas jouer pour
gagner un très très beau cadeau d'accord
mon florian si isabelle morini-bosc
arrive à faire tout le parcours en
gardant un ballon encore gonfler miracle
d'un miracle tu gagnes un énorme cadeau
floflo d'accord pour le flou attention
c'est parti
ben aziza bête tu as tout le temps tu
eux mêmes toutes les missions
il faut que tu gardes le mot abalo
normalement non mais non c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave
et c'est dans l'autre sens meta mais non
mais c'est pas de ça de slalom mathieu
massy vas-y allez vas-y vas-y vas-y
isabelle genou comprenant mort dès la q1
mais ce toit à bso elsa allez vas-y ns
ah mais non mais non attaque est
revendiquée
ouais c'est bien fait attention quand
même va pas de blessé oui il y aurait il
reste encore deux ballons attention
bien que c'est gagné